your target is hello and welcome to
police station grenade it is time for
yet another elusive target on hitman
this is elusive target number 22 the
bookkeeper and he is in Colorado the
worst level comes made in his first
series but right he will run if he gets
spooked at all and if he leaves the
mission then we failed but remember if
you're not sure about how restarting
works in this game please have a look at
the video that I created last week I'll
put it in the description and also put
at the end of the video anyway for this
mission you shall need the lockpick and
instead of the fiber wire you're going
to take some sort of explosive so I'm
going to take the remote-control
explosive duck a lovely red one we're
going to start undercover at the green
house as it's the closest to the target
but you can start pretty much anywhere
as long as you're undercover
I suggest skipping this little intro
video and quickly stop blending in it
and you just going to run round all the
way to the left and our target will be
walking down this road any second now
we're going to use the second cast or
not this first car here but the second
one in fact the third one yeah we use
the third one then use this third
vehicle with our explosive duck and as
he as he comes around the corner we're
going to drop it on the floor so it gets
his attention and then we're going to
get out of the way and we're gonna make
sure no one walks next to him when we
explored the duck I'll make more sense
in a moment so I've dropped the dog
everyone's going a teammate you forgot
your duck but this is because we want to
make sure we only kill one man so as he
walks to the rear of the car when he
gets past the wheel I've just pressed
water and that has only killed him at
this point I could run into the house
and finish the level but I want to make
sure I've only killed that young person
and they have okay next thing we're
going to do we'll run it into this truck
and there should be a militia costume
here it is you're part of the elite now
which means you can get in the house
remember there is CCTV in the house I
forgot on my first run and had to
restart so always jump over this little
balcony and in through the door there is
a key we can use you've got a lock pick
you don't need it but I suggest taking
this key anywhere it's slightly quicker
opening the door Danny
your lockpick unless suspicious to
upstairs there is one gentleman that can
spot you walks down this hall if you are
quick enough you can make it to the
bathroom without him noticing if you're
not if you're a bit slow like me or
you've watched the man die then wait
around when he goes past run upstairs
and hopefully you can never get better
than I I've been playing far too much
wildlands and I'm struggling to use the
controls anyway
unlock this door using your lockpick all
the key we've picked up and inside the
next room just next to the bed on the
left there it is we can now unlock this
this has the ledger inside then it's
just a case of retracing our steps until
we get outside but keep in mind that
gentlemen we saw walk to the balcony
across the top he will walk back so if
you're quite slow there might be a
gentleman walking back you have to avoid
him there just there yes him just at the
top of the stairs okay when you come
outside go left
don't run straight down the path because
you will be spotted by CCTV but once
you've done that you can then swoop back
over to the path and pick whatever you
like to go for the end of the mission
it's that simple it really is and just
run all the way there all the gates that
are locked can be unlocked from the
inside and that's where we are
so you have nothing to worry about done
and dusted I hope that helped I could
have done this 30 seconds quicker but we
wanted to check that our target was
killed
remember if you killed the wrong person
or you get spotted you can restart this
here's the video click on the left here
if you want to look at that video about
how you restart finished thanks for your
time I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
do as a favor and drop as a like and
maybe even subscribe see ya